Let's go to one from Phenix,
Arizona. HL1, what is going on?
What's up, David? How are you doing? I'm good.
I love your show. Thank you. No problem. I'm
just curious about your opinion on people like
John Kasich and the Lincoln Party grifters,
all attacking progressives, even though
progressives won overwhelmingly in progressive
policies, won overwhelmingly on Election Day.
Absolutely. I actually did a segment earlier
this week, which is on the podcast already, but
we're saving it for the weekend on YouTube. And
it's called These Republicans are Not Your Friends
and Mitt Romney, big anti Trump Republican Mitt
Romney. Two days after the election, he was on
TV saying, hey, listen, my priority is stopping
Medicare for all, stopping tax increases, stopping
business regulation, making sure no one stops gas
and oil. John Kasich, as you're pointing out,
anti Trump, Republican, defiant and principled,
goes on TV, says, you know, the Joe Biden better
not let any progressive's influence his policy. So
much like we predicted. These are not our friends.
We use them to the extent that they're useful
for getting rid of Trump. We got rid of Trump.
They're going right back. You know, the debt,
the deficit, all this stuff. These
are not our friends. Full stop.
Yeah, I mean, I agree. One hundred percent.
I just I just think it's interesting. And
then watching AOC try to fight back
against it, I'm just worried that
the Progressive Party is going to take a big hit
if the entire establishment decides that it's bad.
The progressive wing that you're saying, the
progressive wing of the Democratic Party.
Yeah, yeah. But a majority of the Democratic
Party don't even like the progressive wing
of it. So I I'm worried about the progressive
or the progressive wing of the party.
Yeah. No, that's your we talked about
that on the Wednesday Boehner show and
we're going to keep talking about that. But
this is this is an important issue. Listen,
I don't want to hold you up. It sounds like you're
writing a term paper, so I'm going to let you go.
OK, I appreciate a lot of feverish typing
going on there. We don't want to there seems
like important work is happening and we don't
want to get in the way of that. Let's go to
Susan now. It says Susan from L.A. Is that Los
Angeles? Is that Louisiana? From Los Angeles,
Susan from Los Angeles, what's going on?
Oh, what did you.
I was trying to connect yesterday,
but I was wondering about the.
How the McConnell I think it was
McConnell, they're now supporting Trump.
Yeah, I mean, McConnells playing, I mean, listen,
yes, McConnells disgusting and toxic, obviously,
McConnells kind of playing it a little bit coy
by saying the president is entitled to all of
the legal recourse and to demand recounts and
everything. I mean, I'm wondering after it's
certified, I'm wondering what happens after
the certification if Republicans will still
keep kind of playing dumb. My guess is a lot of
them, after the certification on December 14th,
will will start just saying Joe Biden is the
president. But for the time being, very few of
them are straight up just saying, yeah, Biden won
and he's the president elect and it's pretty vile.
It was kind of, oh, frustrating yet. It might
be good is that the Republicans at least?
Their fight. You know, we didn't fight for
Gore enough and how we conceded so early.
Yeah, I mean, to a humiliating degree,
Republicans are just continuing, continuing,
continuing. And you can say that that's virtuous
or that that it's humiliating. I guess it depends
on the situation. But obviously, I would have
liked to have seen Democrats fight more in 2016
with Merrick Garland, with Amy CONI Barrett.
But this is the situation as it stands today.
Yeah. Listen, Susan, what part of L.A. are
you in? I'm right by the airport. Really?
Yeah, I can hear the plane in I
love it. It's called West Chester.
West Chester, like in New York's West Chester.
Yeah. Yeah, love it.
All right, Susan, I hope to be back in L.A. once
it's all settled down, you know, I'll be great.
Yeah. All right, Susan, thank you so much. We're
going to take a quick break, but if you're holding
on to talk to me, please don't hang up. Don't
hang up, my friends, because I'm going to be
going back to the phones momentarily. The
David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.